I what's up everyone its definition here
again with another unboxing this time
it's the DC legion of collectors most
wanted box Richie I didn't really want
this box and then I saw some of the
reviews on the internet and look like it
was gonna be really good so I decided to
purchase it so first thing we've got the
t-shirt it's kind of like a nice villain
one and I quite like that one it's got
Aries Lex Luthor on Joker on black mana
it's got all your favorites all your
best mates who've murdered someone
remember when geocache shot Barbara
Gordon through the spine and crippled er
how what great moment in comic book
history
I like Thor movies customs the funny
ones rich magnets quick me not with the
40 quid I got another badge he's always
come in and it's got black men I never
really liked the character and I started
reading Suicide Squad recently and he's
sort of being drafted into that and he's
a really great addition so yeah looking
forward but now some cool little
stickers
they've got Justice League advert in
there I've literally just been reading
the Justice League reviews this morning
independent gave it about 1 stars I
didn't give it one star so that's gonna
be bloody brilliant hey and the Funko
pop is let's leave that it is on the
suit and ran that one so quite happy
with that one second one it's bloody
bane this is the one I really wanted and
massively happy with that one big I'm a
big fan of the ladder even when he does
he's is voice so yeah thanks for
checking out my review really well you
know that that boxes or I think the
Superman one was better and I think the
Suicide Squad almost slightly better but
you got two Funko pops in it so you
can't complain thanks for checking out
my review take care push